Welcome to the Forge.
Look down at your anvils,
you'll notice
that there's nothing there.
That's because
there's a little twist.
You'll be making
signature blades
using this.
[laughing]
A massive chunk
of twisted elevator cable.
I-I've worked
on cable knives before,
but nothing of that size.
Your three-hour forge time
starts... now.
My plan is to knock
all the crud out of the cable
on the inside of it
so that I can get a clean weld.
Get the grease out,
get the flux in.
Is that a pyrometer?
Paul, is that a pyrometer?
Yes, sir. I like to know
what temperature my steel is
before I quench it.
Wow! That's smart.
A lot of guys judge
temperatures by color,
but when you're forge-welding,
I really like to know exactly
what the temperature is.
Wow, J., I've never seen you
have a total man-crush
on somebody's answer.
[laughing]
Well, actually,
I'm about to break that crush.
I applaud Paul
for bringing the pyrometer,
but it also is a sign
of somebody
who's probably
really meticulous,
and I'm watching Paul trying
to scrub this cable clean,
and that's time wasted.
It's easier to just heat it up
a little bit,
tap it slightly open
to get all that heat in there,
cook all of that out,
and then twist it closed.
Stuff is dirty.
It's gonna weld.
The hardest part
about using cable to make steel
is making sure
that welds will stick,
and I'm afraid
it's just not clean enough.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
-Oh!
-Oh my goodness, man!
That didn't work.
It just falls all apart.
I should've waited
to work on this.
To twist this cable,
you have to get it up to heat.
-Oh, hell.
-Yeah. This is done.
I can grab another piece
of cable and start again,
but I don't... I don't like
the cable to begin with
in terms of its cleanliness,
you know?
I just decide
it's gonna be a canister.
It's a workaround,
but is it a legit workaround?
We didn't say they needed
to make cable Damascus.
We said they needed to work
with that cable.
Canister Damascus is something
I've never done before.
But I just feel like
the process is more foolproof
than taking a risk on the cable
just not welding well.
Something that he's never done
before. That's a ballsy move.
[Wil] Steven doesn't have
the time
to make a mistake
with a canister.
That is a lot of pressure.
That's my new plan.
Let's just look over here
at Robert.
He's got a huge pipe wrench
on that cable,
and he's twisting it up.
That's what we expect to see,
is it not?
Right, and if you do
the cable properly,
as you twist it, it'll actually
start forge-welding.
Wow.
[J.] And see, Paul,
everything's staying tight.
He put a lot of weld on the end.
See, there's the difference
between Paul and Ryan there.
I might have to fold this.
It's not wide enough.
It's getting a little longer
and leaner than I really want.
I have to fold it
and get it thick enough
so that I'd have something
to work with.
[all exclaiming]
[laughing]
[Robert]
Who designed that hammer?
That's a guy
who hits metal hard.
[J.] What the heck
is Steven doin'?
He's standing there
watching everybody else.
[Steven] I give the canister
30 minutes in the forge
because I want that thing to be
hot enough to set the weld.
So for that 30 minutes,
I'm standing here sweatin'.
It's not going to weld
itself together.
I'm standing here stringing
curse words together to myself.
Steven! You all right?
Yeah, I'm just waitin' for heat.
-Just making sure.
-Yeah.
I... I'm not looking
very smart right now.
-It's gotta be hot, right?
-Got to be hot.
Here we go.
Steven's on the move.
I can't really see
if it's hot enough or not.
Well, that went...
There went that.
-I hope it's nothing serious.
-No!
Not welded. [bleep]
Steven's shaking his head,
but, like, it looks pretty good.
-Yeah, I'd keep going.
-He's got plenty of heat.
He's gotta be fast. He's gotta
catch up to these other smiths.
I'm not out of the woods yet.
Still need to harden this blade.
[Robert] I'm pleased
with the shape,
and I've gotta get
this thing in the oil.
Pull it out, and I got a warp.
Fortunately, it's still warm.
I can move it.
You don't very often see
a smith smacking
on a blade with a hammer
right after he quenched it.
Because there's a chance of
shattering the blade, correct?
Paul, getting ready.
[intense music playing]
Blade's hard, I'm like, "Yeah,
that's what I'm here to do."
[Doug] Steve just quenched
his blade.
Steven has made up
a lot of ground here.
Three, two, one!
Bladesmiths,
shut down your machines
'cause this round is over!
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test,
the wire cable chop.
I'm going to take
each of your blades,
I'm gonna baton them
three times
at three different points.
Keep in mind, it's not what
your blade can do to this cable.
It's what the cable's gonna do
to your blades.
Steven, what do you think?
I think we might be in trouble.
When I see the cable wire,
I'm even more worried
than I was before
because it's so thick.
There's a good chance that
my blade will just snap in half.
[hard rock music playing]
[music fades]
[laughs]
[J.] Well, Steven,
it held up pretty well.
You do have some wrinkling,
especially
on the first two strikes.
Third one, not as much.
But the handle's nice and tight.
Nice job.
So you saw that, Paul.
What are you thinkin'? Ready?
Uh, I'm as ready as I can be.
[suspenseful music playing]
[intense music playing]
[music fades]
[tense music playing]
[J.] Well, Paul,
you definitely have some
chipping out on the edge here,
especially
on the last two strikes.
But stayed in alignment.
Everything's tight. Nice job.
What are you thinkin', Robert?
The steam hammer in my chest
says, "Let's get her done."
Well, that's it.
It's gonna break.
There's no way he can put
that weak spot
on hardened cable
and it'll stay.
[intense music playing]
[music fades]
[suspenseful music playing]
[J.] Well, Robert, it survived.
But that crack at the edge
has opened up now.
There's definitely
separation damage
from the initial break.
Definitely had a chipping out
on the three spots I struck.
That being said,
you made the best
of a bad situation.
-Good job.
-Thank you.
Doug?
Bladesmiths, this is
the sharpness test.
To see how sharp
your blade is,
I will take your weapon
and attempt to cut
through this fire hose.
-Steven, you're up first. Ready?
-Yes, sir.
In round one,
the judges didn't really like
the little whoopty thing
in the edge.
I was able to make
a lot of improvement,
but there's always a chance
that something could go wrong.
[intense music playing]
[music fades]
Wow.
Okay, Steven.
First of all, your handle.
It is wide.
Because of its wideness,
it keeps wanting to turn over.
But barring that,
your edge is very sharp.
Your blade will cut.
Thanks.
[Doug] Paul, you're up next.
[intense music playing]
Okay, Paul.
This feels very good
in the hand.
Not only do I feel like
I can cut forward,
but immediately I'm ready
to do follow-up thrusting
or another slash.
Overall, your blade will cut.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Good job.
Robert, you're up next.
[Robert] Since that crack
opened up a bit,
I'm really worried
about the blade catching
and just halting mid-stroke.
[dramatic music playing]
Okay, Robert.
Your design here
is a nice, clean arc
that allows for a good slice.
You definitely gave us
a chopper here.
Your weapon, sir, will cut.
Thank you.
[Wil] Bladesmiths, the judges
have made their final decision,
and it's time for one of you
to leave the Forge.
[dramatic music playing]
Robert, your blade
did not make the cut.
Robert, you did something
we've never had happen
on this competition.
You came back
from a catastrophic
blade failure,
found a workaround,
and actually made it
into the testing
of that weapon.
But in the end,
your blade took more damage
than the other blades,
and we've gotta let you go.
Understand.
Robert, pleasure surrender
your blade.
[Robert] I would love
to move on,
but my best lessons
have been through failure.
So just being here is a win.
And my family, they'll be happy
I didn't give up.
They'll just revert back to,
"Oh, yeah, that's MacGyver.
He'll figure something out."